So if you thought that the United States had
become a global laughingstock thanks to Donald
Trump before three days ago, then the US has
really doubly a laughing stock right now.
The world is literally laughing at the United
States because we have a dangerous fool as
president who is still supported by tens of
millions of Americans who recently suggested
we should look into injecting bleach in isopropyl
alcohol to treat coronavirus.
Here is the chief medical officer in Australia,
Brendan Murphy, struggling.
If you're watching, you'll see him visibly
struggling not to laugh as he takes a question
from the Australian media about Donald Trump
talking about hitting the body internally
with heat, light and disinfectants during
Thursday's White House coronavirus press briefing
last week.
Professor, today at a briefing, Donald Trump
said that, quote, a tremendous hit, unquote,
of ultraviolet light could see off the virus.
He also referenced the effectiveness of disinfectant
and wondered whether injections of disinfectant
might also be effective.
Given that this is coming from the president,
the United States, an influential person.
Is there any scientific basis to either of
these propositions?
I would not.
I would caution against the injection of disinfection.
There is.
They could be quite toxic to people.
I'm not I wasn't privy to his comments.
So I would be very careful about commenting
on something that I didn't hear myself certain.
And ultraviolet light.
I don't know the context in which he said
it, so I really would need to study it and
and before I could comment.
Thank you.
If you watched the clip, you see the Australian
chief medical officer having difficulty to
avoid bursting out laughing because that's
what the world is currently doing.
They're laughing at us and some also just
feel really bad for us.
I got a number of nice messages over the weekend,
including from friends of mine in other countries,
Netherlands, Italy, other spots from family
in Argentina, from viewers in Canada, all
who who are essentially saying, we're really
sorry for what you're dealing with.
We're all dealing with the virus.
But you were in addition to that or dealing
with Donald Trump.
Here is the UK deputy chief medical officer.
Also, ever asked about disinfectant injections?
Now, Donald Trump being treated globaly as
a vector of disinformation that must be debunked
time and again.
This to come back on one more thing.
Many people in the UK will have seen the clip
overnight of the president of the United States
suggesting coronavirus might be treated by
injecting disinfectant into the body.
He has a message to Donald Trump about the
dangers of spreading dangerous defs disinformation
when governments around the world are trying
to combat it spread from other sources.
Here, I'll defer to medical expertise.
So I wouldn't have a specific message to Donald
Trump.
I'd have a specific message to anybody who
suggested they should be injecting anything
into their bodies.
I mean, clearly, we would not support from
a medical professional perspective.
It is really important that people use appropriate
treatments that are evidence based and tested.
We have very good programs that have been
taken at very rapidly coordination in this
country, testing various different alternative
treatments.
Those trials will report reasonably early,
but certainly nobody should be injecting anything
and we should be using evidence based and
properly trialed treatments that we know will
be safe.
World disclaimers and corporations like the
makers of Lysol having to clarify now don't
even think about doing this.
Here is Nicola Sturgeon, the first minister
of Scotland.
Also having to answer a similar question,
actually saying what Trump said could be dangerous.
There's a big responsibility on all leaders
right now.
There's always a responsibility on leaders,
but it's greater than ever during a crisis
like this.
And I have said it today.
I said it yesterday.
I'm really keen that we have an open discussion
with the public and that politicians unusually
perhaps are prepared to admit things they
don't know as well as share the thinking on
the things that we do know and are trying
to work through.
But the responsibility of leaders is not to
stand up in a public platform and repeat things
that you have perhaps half hared and perhaps
completely misunderstood and present that
to the public in a way that the public might
tone.
And that could be dangerous.
And none of us are perfect and we will all
make mistakes in this.
But I think we all have to remember that very
serious
responsibility when we giving advice to the
public.
It must be good advice.
A informed.
But by the best science.
And as Jason has just said, it is clearly
not the case that ingesting disinfectant in
any way, shape or form is a good idea.
It is a very, very bad idea and extremely
dangerous.
And there are more from all around the world.
I won't play them all for you today, but this
is now what the world is dealing with.
We're all dealing with the virus and the world
is having to come together.
Corporate America and foreign leaders all
having to come together to say when Trump
wondered aloud about injecting disinfectants.
That was a bad idea.
Don't do it.
Some of them are having trouble not laughing
when they're asked about it.
You also, by the way, have poison control
centers receiving phone calls.
One example is from Maryland.
The governor, Larry Hogan in Maryland is a
Republican.
He's no left wing bomb thrower, not a Democrat,
said Trump was sending the wrong message with
the bleach fiasco and that his state over
the weekend received hundreds of calls wondering
if it is safe to ingest cleaning products
as a result
of Donald Trump's statement.
Check out the Republican governor here explaining
it.
Many of your citizens didn't see it as sarcasm.
Is that how you took it?
Well, look, I think it's really important.
This is a bit important to me from day one
about communicating very clearly on the facts
because people listen to these press conferences.
They listen when the governor holds a press
conference and they certainly pay attention
when the president of the United States is
standing there giving a press conference about
something as serious as this worldwide pandemic.
And I think when misinformation comes out
or you just say something that pops in your
head, it does send a wrong message.
And we had hundreds of calls come into our
emergency hotline and our health department
asking if it was if it was right to ingest
Clorox or, you know, alcohol cleaning products,
whether that was going to help them fight
the virus.
So we had to put out that warning to make
sure that people were not doing something
like
that, which would kill people actually to
do it.
So that's what happens when the guy who thinks
the Nobel Prize is the Nobel Prize, A.B.,
Ali, it gets really bad and it's gotten very,
very bad.
And again, an unforced error.
And we will see what today's press briefing
looks like after all of this